Leute die Forscher in der
Entwicklungsbiologie sind gerade echt
zwiegespalten denn seit diesem Jahr
werden in Labors synthetische
menschliche Embryonen hergestellt und
das ist mega krass für die Wissenschaft
sind sie ein echter Meilenstein in der
Erforschung der menschlichen Entwicklung
und das könnte z.B helfen
Schwangerschaften besser begleiten zu
können oder vielleicht sogar eines Tages
Körperteile für die Transplantation im
Reagenzglas wachsen zu lassen okay Grund
sich zu fragen sind synthetische
Embryonen künstliche Menschen müssen wir
die Grenzen für die Embryonenforschung
verschieben und geht das nicht alles zu
weit genau das besprechen wir jetzt bei
dr
[Musik]
Watson wenn du noch nach einem kreativen
Weihnachtsgeschenk suchst dann schau
doch mal auf drwatson.shop vorbei denn
da gibt es tourtickets für meine Tour
nächstes Jahr im März ich komme in acht
verschiedene Städte in Deutschland
Österreich und der Schweiz und es gibt
noch ein extra Tourstop zusammen mit
anderen creatorn machen wir mindblown
University XXL in Düsseldorf und wenn
ihr da jetzt bis zum 24 Dezember ein
Ticket kauft dann gibt es noch was zu
gewinnen es lohnt sich also wie gesagt
alle tickets gibt's unter drwatson.shop
es wirürd mich sehr freuen Euch mal live
zu sehen jetzt geht's aber weiter mit
dem Video mit synthetischen menschlichen
Embryonen meinen die Forscherinnen und
Forscher keine vollständig neu designen
Menschen wie man vielleicht denken
könnte im Gegenteil sie sollen als
Modelle dienen die man anstelle von
echten Embryonen erforschen kann deshalb
sollen sie dem auch Original so ähnlich
wie möglich sein aber gleichzeitig auch
nicht zu ähnlich warum dazu kommen wir
gleich im Kern geht es bei synthetischen
Embryonen um Stammzellen denn daraus
werden sie gemacht Stammzellen sind ganz
besondere Zellen wenn die sich teilen
dann entstehen nicht zwei identische
Tochterzellen sondern eine neue
Stammzelle und eine Zelle einer
bestimmten Sorte also eine Stammzelle
und dann z.B eine Leberzelle oder
Hautzelle oder Nervenzellen je nachdem
worauf die Stammzelle spezialisiert ist
das nennt man dann Differenzierung
vollständig ausdifferenzierte Zellen
können sich nicht mehr Teilen im Körper
braucht man deshalb Stammzellen überall
da wo neue Zellen gemacht werden müssen
und wo brauchen wir neue Zellen ganz
besonders natürlich da wo ganz neue
Menschen entstehen müssen also in
Embryonen 5 Tage nach der Befruchtung
der Eizelle besitzt ein Embryo mehrere
sogenannte pluripotente Stammzellen
pluripotent heißt dass sie fast alle
Sorten von Zellen und ganze zellgeebe
produzieren können aus denen der spätere
Embryo besteht also z.B Gewebe das
später zur Haut wird Gewebe das zu
inneren Organen wird und so weiter und
forschende können aus pluripotenten
Stammzellen alle möglichen Gewebe im
Labor züchten und dann erforschen um
synthetische Embryonen herzustellen
werden die pluripotenten Stammzellen
dazu gebracht all die verschiedenen
Zellen zu produzieren die in einem
Embryo so drin sind und
erstaunlicherweise setzen sie sich sogar
selbständig zu zu dreidimensionalen
Strukturen zusammen die echten Embryonen
im Alter von ca 8 bis 14 Tagen sehr
ähnlich sehen können sie werden also
nicht im Stadium von Tag 0 erzeugt und
wachsen dann 14 Tage heran sondern sie
werden direkt im Stadium von Tag 8 bis
14 gebaut und so sehen die synthetischen
Embryonen dann aus ziemlich krass dass
wir Menschen dazu in der Lage sind aber
jetzt natürlich die berechtigte Frage
wozu das Ganze wie ein Mensch entsteht
ist eine der grundlegendsten Fragen der
Biologie und dabei geht es nicht nur um
einen Beitrag zum fundamentalen
Verständnis darüber was uns zum Menschen
macht vor allem geht es um medizinischen
Fortschritt die Grundlagenforschung
könnte uns vielleicht helfen zu
verstehen warum so viele Fehlgeburten in
den ersten 12 Wochen der Schwangerschaft
passieren eine andere Anwendung wäre
Organe und Gliedmaßen wachsen zu lassen
um sie dann in Patienten zu
transplantieren aber vor allem und jetzt
wird es spannend kann man mit dieser
Methode Dinge erforschen die man bisher
nicht legal erforschen konnte denn wir
haben Gesetze die die Erforschung von
menschlichen Embryonen begrenzen
schließlich ermöglichen die dafür
angewandten Forschungsmethoden
prinzipiell das Klonen und die
gentechnische Manipulation von Menschen
und da muss man verschiedene Fragen
gegeneinander abwergen ab wann ist ein
Mensch ein Mensch hat ein Embryo eigene
Freiheitsrechte und falls ja wiegen sie
schwerer als die Rechte und Bedürfnisse
der Gesellschaft auf medizinischen
Fortschritt und was ist mit den
Bedürfnissen der biologischen Eltern ihr
seht da hängt schon ganz schön viel dran
weil das natürlich die Forschenden
selbst auch erkennen hat die
international Society for stem cell
research sich basierend auf einem
früheren Report von
1985 selbst feste ethische
Handlungsrichtlinien gegeben sie
verbieten Embryonen über das
Entwicklungsstadium von Tag 14 hinaus
für die Forschung zu verwenden ab diesem
Tag entsteht der sogenannte
Primitivstreifen der die Körperachsen
definiert also wo im Organismus ist oben
und unten und wo ist vorn und hinten die
14 tageregel ist keine endgültige Lösung
der ethischen abwgungen von Rechten und
Bedürfnissen der Embryonen genauso wenig
wie die der Eltern und der Gesellschaft
aber die isscr will mit dieser Grenze
eine absichtlich frühgewählte Linie
ziehen und der Gesellschaft versichern
dass Stammzellforschung nicht
unkontrolliert fortschreiten kann viele
Länder darunter auch Deutschland haben
Gesetze erlassen die dieser
Selbstverpflichtung der Wissenschaft
folgen
aber hier kommt genau der große
Knackpunkt weswegen die synthetischen
Embryonen so ein großer Deal sind das
embryonenchutzgesetz und das
Stammzellgesetz definieren einen Embryo
darüber dass er aus einer befruchteten
Eizelle oder aus embryonalen Stammzellen
hervorgegangen ist aber wegen genau
dieser Definition kann man das Gesetz
umgehen denn schon seit 2006 gibt es die
Möglichkeit pluripotente Stammzellen
herzustellen statt sie Embryonen zu
entnehmen und und zwar nimmt man dafür
ausdifferenzierte Körperzellen von
erwachsenen Menschen und behandelt sie
mit bestimmten Stoffen daraufhin wandeln
sie sich in pluripotente Stammzellen um
und das nennt man dann induzierte
pluripotente Stammzellen man kann also
synthetische Embryonen herstellen ohne
befruchtete Keimzellen oder embryonale
Stammzellen zu benutzen und das ist mega
krass denn das bedeutet Forscherinnen
und Forscher können legal synthetische
Embryonen in Entwicklungsstadien nach
Tag 14 erzeugen und manipulieren sie
dürfen sie nur nicht in eine Gebärmutter
implantieren okay heißt das dass man
diese Embryonen jetzt unbegrenzt
heranwachsen lassen kann kann so ein
Embryo theoretisch zu einem künstlichen
Menschen werden dazu kommen wir gleich
aber vorher habe ich noch einen Tipp für
euch denn eure personenbezogene Daten
müsst ihr immer auf xbiebigen
Internetportalen angeben und gerade
jetzt zur Weihnachtszeit beim Geschenke
shoppen ist das ja extrem nervig mein
digitaler Fußabdruck wächst und wächst
mit jedem Mal und durch den cogny weiß
ich inzwischen auch dass nicht jede
Internetseite gut damit umgeht niemand
will dass persönliche Daten für
kommerzielle Zwecke missbraucht werden
oder und das noch viel schlimmer in ganz
falsche Hände geraten der Handel mit
unseren Daten ist längst Realität und
genau deshalb gibt es incogni incogni
hilft euch zu erkennen wo ihr welche
Informationen hinterlassen habt sei eure
Adresse euer Name Fotos von euch oder
gar eure Bankdaten um loszulegen und
diese Daten sichtbar zu machen müsst ihr
nur eure E-Mailadresse angeben und in
einem zweiten Schritt kann in cognitan
datenlöschanträge für euch stellen bei
mir persönlich waren das direkt beim
ersten mal 60 Löschanträge die
rausgingen und ich konnte sehen welche
Daten von mir gehandelt und für welchen
Zweck sie weiter verkauft wurden und das
war ziemlich gruselig wenn ihr auch
wollt dass eure Daten aus dem Netz
verschwinden und sie niemand mehr weiter
verkaufen kann dann schaut mal bei
incogy vorbei der Link befindet sich
immer unten in der Videobeschreibung und
mit unserem Code dr Watson bekommt ihr
außerdem noch 60% Rabatt auf ein
Jahresabo so schützt ihr nicht nur euch
sondern unterstützt auch noch unsere
Videos und falls ihr nicht zufrieden
seid gibt es wie immer natürlich 30 Tage
Geld zurückgarantie okay das ist die
Situation bis hierhin forschende und
Gesetzgeber haben vor vielen Jahren
beschlossen dass Forschung an Embryonen
wichtig und richtig ist aber nur solange
die Embryonen nicht zu weit entwickelt
sind das ist die 14 Tage Regel die
Gesetze definieren Embryonen aber ganz
speziell nach ihrem Ursprung also
Embryonen sind dann Embryonen wenn sie
aus Keimzellen also eizell plus Spermium
entstanden sind oder wenn sie aus
embryonalen Stammzellen hervorgegangen
sind wie man sie an Tag 5 in Embryonen
findet die neuen synthetischen Embryonen
kann man aber aus den Zellen von
erwachsenen Menschen machen deshalb darf
man sie bisher noch in späteren
Entwicklungsstadien erzeugen und sogar
gentechnisch verändern rechtlich ist
diese Argumentation wasserdicht die
forschungscommunity reagiert aber mit
gemischten Gefühlen vielleicht müssen
wir deshalb neu definieren was ein o
überhaupt ist die Forscherinnen und
Forscher schlagen vor dass alles als
schützenswerter Embryo gilt aus dem ein
Baby werden könnte in anderen Worten
wenn die synthetischen Embryonen dem
Original so ähnlich werden dass sie zu
künstlichen Menschen heranwachsen können
dann sollte man auch sie wie echte
Embryonen behandeln und jetzt die Frage
aller Fragen ist das denn der Fall nun
die Forscher die sich dazu äußern haben
ausgewogene Meinungen dazu aber sie
betonen doch unter chiedliche Aspekte
der Diskussion dr vin fleed vom maxbank
Institut für molekulare Zellbiologie und
Genetik betont z.B dass die Modelle also
die synthetischen Embryonen eben nicht
mit echten Embryonen identisch sind nur
wenige von ihnen etwa 3% sein im
Original sehr ähnlich aber eben nicht
identisch außerdem durchlaufen die
Modelle nicht die verschiedenen Phasen
der Entwicklung stattdessen wenn Sie in
einem bestimmten Entwicklungsstadium
erzeugt indem natürliche Embryonen die
Fähigkeit verloren haben sich in eine
gebärm Mutter einzunisten und ohne
Gebärmutter könne sich kein Baby
entwickeln insgesamt hätte also ein
synthetischer Embryo seiner Ansicht nach
nie das Potenzial gehabt ein Mensch zu
werden das ist die Situation heute aber
Dr byani vom MPI für molekulare
Biomedizin vermutet dass man in relativ
wenigen Jahren synthetische Embryonen
von Mäusen erzeugen kann die zu
mäusewelpen heranwachsen könnten man hat
bei Mäusen sogar schon embryoide mit Sch
end den Herzen erzeugt und das ganz ohne
Gebärmutter die synthetischen
menschlichen Embryonen werden derzeit
auf sehr ähnliche Weise hergestellt wie
die Mausmodelle deswegen könnte es
möglich sein dass synthetische
menschliche Embryonen irgendwann die
Fähigkeit bekommen sich potenziell zu
Babys zu entwickeln wenn man sie lässt
ob das der Fall sein wird ist natürlich
noch nicht klar aber in den Augen von Dr
buyani wären synthetische Embryonen in
diesem Fall den natürlichen Embryonen
gleichzustellen wenn der Gesetzgeber das
nicht tut könnte das ein legaler Weg zum
Klonen von Menschen werden das ist ein
krasser Satz aber natürlich bleibt die
Frage wer hat denn jetzt hier recht
gehen synthetische Embryonen zu weit das
kann man leider nicht so richtig sagen
denn diese beiden Ansichten schließen
sich eigentlich nicht gegenseitig aus
die richtige Frage ist eher wann gehen
synthetische Embryonen zu weit während
sie heute sicherlich nicht nah genug ans
Original herankommen um Babys
hervorzubringen könnten synthetische
Embryonen von morgen das vielleicht
schon diese Standpunkte kommen auch in
diesem Artikel hier zum Thema zusammen
hier schlagen die Autoren vor dass man
von Modellen spricht bis die Konstrukte
eines Tages in der Lage sind sich
vollständig zu entwickeln dann sollte
man schlicht von Embryonen sprechen denn
das ist das was sie dann sind was
natürlich noch zu klären bleibt ist die
Frage woran erkennt man dass ein
synthetischer Embryo zu einem
künstlichen Menschen heranwachsen kann
und das kann man nur rausfinden indem
man es ausprobiert aber dann ist es ja
schon geschehen deshalb ist es gut dass
wir die Methoden der
Entwicklungsbiologie immer erstmal an
Tieren
entwickeln diese synthetischen Embryonen
herzustellen ist schon eine großartige
wissenschaftliche Leistung die
Forscherinnen und Forscher würden sie
natürlich sehr gerne dazu benutzen um
spätere Embryonalstadien zu erforschen
als es heute möglich ist sie wissen aber
natürlich auch dass es dringend ein
Update der gesetzlichen Regulierung und
der Diskussion geben muss sollten wir an
synthetischen Embryonen nach Tag 14
forschen dürfen oder nicht sollten wir
sie als menschlich anerkennen und
entsprechend schützen die Frage die
dahinter steht ist so groß dass sie ein
einzelner Wissenschaftler ganz sicher
nicht beantworten kann und garantiert
auch kein Youtuber denn wer auch immer
die Entscheidung fällt definiert neu was
es bedeutet ein Mensch zu sein und
deswegen finde ich das ist eines dieser
Probleme wo man einfach den richtigen
Leuten vertrauen muss wir haben in
diesem Video vor allem die Seite der
Entwicklungsbiologie gehört wichtig ist
natürlich aber auch was ethikkmissionen
dazu sagen werden und ich bin schon sehr
gespannt ob das embryonens Schutzgesetz
und das Stammzellgesetz bald
umgeschrieben werden und wie das dann
aussieht wenn ihr hier zuu Updates haben
wollt dann folgt uns auf jeden Fall auf
Instagram @d Watson da werden wir auf
jeden Fall was dazu posten wenn es
passiert und in diesem Sinne danke fürs
zuschauen und bleibt wie immer neugierig
euer Cedric